you can just about make out the road
parts of sao paulo state are under water
after two days of torrential rains
rescuers now having to use boats to
navigate above the roads
the rescue efforts continued through the
night thousands of people have been made
homeless due to the flooding
unfortunately it's been raining since
yesterday and is flooded over other
parts of the river it hadn't flooded
here until now it started flooding and
it has just started to go down
they've also been landslides causing a
number of deaths as homes collapsed the
earth giving way under the force of the
rains
this government handout video shows the
devastation from above
sao paulo's governor announced almost
three million dollars in aid to help
those affected
i came here to see the current situation
and the effects and intensity of the
rain
also unfortunately of the landslides
victims and fatalities here in this
region
brazil has seen various incidents of
severe flooding since the rainy season
began in october the rescue efforts are
now switching to a cleanup effort
images like these a reminder of just how
powerless we are in the face of nature
stephanie decker al jazeera